hey guys welcome back to design patterns
my name is matt and you're watching go
tekken tutorials
now we're going to look at the observer
pattern this pattern is one of the most
common and you've seen it everywhere
pretty much because it is a very it's uh
it's a subscriber pattern anything that
you can subscribe to typically uses this
pattern as you it is also used a lot in
code or
anything that might want to observe
what's happening somewhere else without
being directly involved so we're going
to go over
in general how to implement this and all
the stuff you need to know so i've
worked up some code and gone through a
lot of examples but i want to make sure
that this
is a good tutorial so let me know if
there's things i could do better
ultimately what this pattern does is
well
let's just go over here
there's a pattern to allow notifications
to be sent to anyone who subscribes
overall the point is to have users is
not to have users manually check
something rather to be notified whenever
a certain event happens to a subject
well it's very common especially in gui
components and stuff like that and it
allows a nice way of reacting so what do
we need to implement something like this
well first of all we need some sort of
publishing service
a publishing service is something that's
going to go with your business logic
and here we're calling it a subject this
is just a somewhat demo one i worked up
so your publishing service which might
be combined with your business logic
you'll probably want some sort of
interface and the default one will look
something like this you have a way to
add subscribers you have a way to remove
them and you have a way to notify them
and you do need to implement these
within your business so you might have
say some subject i just call it subject
here but it could be anything and it's
gonna use this interface so we need to
implement these methods and these take a
subscriber interface
and these are all these are all pointers
and the reason these are pointers is
because it makes it easy for us to move
stuff around and add and remove quickly
so let's take a look at the subscriber
interface as this is important as well
so from the subscribers standpoint this
would be the end that you connect to the
publishing service the only thing it has
is an update and this is typically
called by your subject and the notify
now you do get to implement this update
as the subscriber end so you can have
this do whatever you want and also you
need to pass in associated data in this
case we're just using a message a string
message as the thing that uh comes
through as an update but this could be
anything this could be any sorts of uh
any sort of data points it could be an
entire class with all sorts of details
sometimes
they even pass in the entire subject
itself which would look something like
well rather than latest message you
would put you would just pass in the
entire subject that actually happens too
something like this or store this but in
this case we're just going to pass in
just this latest message okay so we have
a publishing interface
um there's a few other things we need to
add to it we're gonna need some sort of
array of all the subscribers so we know
who is subscribed and who to notify
and these would be called also the
observers so that's something we would
need to implement here
and there it is it's very important that
all the subscribers use the same
interface and with that in mind
you could make a subscriber and a
subject relationship in a pretty broad
number of ways you could have lots of
different types of subscribers and lots
of different types of subjects ours is
going to be a little stripped down like
from your perspective on say youtube you
have a way to look at everything you're
subscribed to we're not implementing
that but if you were to implement that
you would think uh well here in this
class too you would also need another
array of all the subjects
so and you would also need of course
keep those updated now we need to think
about what exactly do we want to publish
this all depends on your business logic
so
you might call notify and update all
your subscribers at certain events
within your business logics for our case
we're just going to do it whenever we
call this function advance and update
all this is just a pseudo function
that basically
is going to keep a static number and for
each one it's just going to increment
and set the latest message to update
number whatever it is processed and then
call notify at the end and when we call
notify as long as there are subs we will
go through and update all of them with
the latest message and you can see well
one of the nice reasons to use a list
in this case a list of pointers is that
we can just use very simple methods with
low overhead taking advantage of the
standard template library for
push back and remove now there are some
problems here like you wouldn't want to
add duplicates so you'd want to check
for duplicates and that sort of thing
and there might be a few cleanup steps
that are missed here in this code but
it's just a sample
and you'll have to of course think about
that and implement that as needed but in
general this is a pretty good skeleton
so your subject does call and tell when
to notify but your subscriber interface
that you have implemented
which is uh what is actually added here
that's what processes the update so
you'll have some control there in our
case we just get a message and what do
we do with that message
well right now we're just putting a
console out of this sub id received
message and then the message and i have
developed a bit of a system to make this
each subscriber have a unique id as well
using a static to increment them just a
little hack there
so that if we add and remove and go
through all kinds of state changes we
don't get any overlap once again of
course your implementation for whatever
you're doing is probably going to be a
little more robust based on what you
need
so when you're implementing this you
need to decide things like
okay what is my core business logic of
my code
and when do i want to
publish notifications to anyone who is
wanting to observe it so this varies
greatly you can see this
all over a code of all different sorts
like in game code for example you might
have observers in place for when to uh
do certain things play particle effects
play sounds stuff like that or maybe
trigger certain events it can get as
complicated as you want and that's kind
of the point is you can just use this
pattern to simplify some of the things
down once you have a lot of stuff going
on but you want other things to know
about it too without necessarily having
direct access to the whole class or
anything like that that's when you might
want to register observers now there is
a way to do this with composition as
well
where instead of this interface class
like so
or i guess it would be more for the
subject you would instead have this
already predefined and then just add it
for example i suppose we could extend
that here without too much trouble we go
something like this
special
subject and then privately we would have
the subject from above that is a
concrete
class with all these functions and have
it just privately like so probably
probably as a pointer and then when you
uh implement this
you could
just go subject equals new subject and
get it instantiated that way but then
you would also still need to forward all
of these main functions here
and rather than oh anything like this
directly since subject holds all that
data we just use this one like so
and this is sort of getting into more of
like the the pimple idiom and stuff like
that so
it's just another option but you do see
this in code sometimes gotta get rid of
all these overrides because these aren't
overrides they're just forwarding
to the implementation
so just another way of doing it and you
don't need all this you just call
subject notify
and there you go there's how you would
do it with uh composition rather than
inheritance uh you could just work up
this one without the inheritance at all
if you want it and then
do it like so so that's pretty standard
to the composition and those are some
different ways of doing it there
and of course you would still have to
have your core business logic that calls
notify and also you would probably want
to have a way to uh set the message
within it so right now it's still only
going to do the same thing but you have
to call advance on it and we don't
actually have a way to do that at the
moment from the special one that we've
made so it's just uh more things to
think about depending on how you're
doing it
but uh i'm kind of jumping around so
seems like there's a bit of oversight
i'm going to delete this special subject
because it's going to make things
complicated but just keep in mind that
that's a way of doing things as well and
still accomplishing the same effect
without using inheritance if you're
really afraid of inheritance or if it
just isn't for your code okay so let's
go ahead and play around with this and
instantiate stuff so we make a new
subject i'm just calling it channel
and uh just instantiate it right there
and uh same with subscriber let's make a
new subscriber or an account or whatever
you want to call it and then we're just
going to
add the subscriber to a channel call the
update so we should just get update one
on subscriber one or something like that
let's go ahead and press play there it
is
subject or sub id one received message
update number one process so you can see
we could call this again and it would
update all the subscribers there's only
one subscriber so they're the only one
getting updated but if we did add
another one at some point subscriber 2
and also added it to the channel and
then called some updates processed
further updates obviously they won't get
past ones but you know such as the
reality if you don't subscribe you miss
out and hint hint hint all right then we
hit play again you'll see that at first
it's only once and then it's going to
alternate between one and two with the
rest of those updates and make sure they
both get them see they both get eight
they both get seven et cetera so as you
go through and your code is live or your
server is live or whatever and it's
adding removing anytime it's pushing
updates it's only pushing updates to all
the people who want it well that's
pretty much the example i came up with
hope you enjoyed the explanation and
that to make sense if you want to look
at some more stuff there is a great
reference place uh this refactoring dot
guru slash design patterns
you can find it they have observer there
they have a cpp example uh it's a little
different than mine but it's another
option
they also have a lots of details i got
some general notes of my takeaway of
things after looking at some stuff but
uh yeah head on over to that site if
you're still confused have a read over
that and yeah it'll click but just in
general though their example was
something like this they made an
observer class
they made a subject class well these are
interfaces and they did about the same
thing they have a detach attach and
detach instead of add remove notify does
about the same thing they have a few
other little helper functions in there
there's their business logic there's the
latest message list of observers and
here's their observer which you see they
defined last they do take a subject in
here and uh set everything set that
whole attach up and uh you can see here
at the bottom they hold the subject but
this is a single subject system as well
but they want to have the uh remove me
from the list option there directly from
this uh so normally you probably
interface with all the ones that you
have access to and attempt to remove and
uh or something along those lines so
that's their example and there's their
client main
um basically they just make a subject
take some observers uh to that subject
and uh just create some messages
whenever they do create message i
believe it updates their notify you know
anytime they do some business logic it
also does notify but changes the message
so they just have a few different little
scenarios in there and there we go we
can just go ahead and hit play
let's switch it to the that observer
and there you go
looks like it's uh as you would expect
you can see they got options for passing
in custom messages and uh be sure to
delete your pointers if you're not using
shared or unique
all right that's gonna do it for this
one hope you guys have learned some
stuff about how to uh set up an observer
or subscriber system here in c plus plus
and about the pattern and what it's
useful for feel free to drop a comment
drop a like and a huge shout out to my
patrons helping uh keep the lights on
and keeping these tutorials going so
i'll show you guys on screen and i
greatly appreciate it and if anyone else
wants to help out you're always welcome
over there
and uh yeah just check the channel page
we have some other community links as
well like a discord where you can talk
about code and your projects and stuff
it'll be fun all right i'll catch you
guys later if you have a good one keep
coding and peace out
[Music]